Carrie Underwood reveals the secret to
her seriously toned physique doesn't
have to be complicated all glammed up or
dressed down in sweats there's no
denying Carrie Underwood's bod is 100%
flawless ET was with the singer on
Sunday at the American country countdown
Awards where she revealed exactly what
she does to get such incredible results
you don't need that much I mean I like
free weights and a BOSU and you're in
business maybe a medicine ball I do lots
of squats and lunges and I like to run I
like to run outside but I just you know
bodyweight stuff push-ups pull-ups
doesn't have to be complicated all that
exercise has clearly paid off just look
at Carrie in this stunning peekaboo
number she rocked on the red carpet it
was like a gown but I had a romper
underneath it was super fun thank you I
have to wonder what Mike says while
you're getting ready is he ever disliked
dancer he's uh he probably hasn't seen
anything from tonight because he's
currently playing a game does he ever
chime in on what he likes to see you in
or what kinds of styles no I don't care
I love him okay so yeah maybe her hubby
Mike Fisher doesn't talk fashion but he
does sing check him out with Garth
Brooks and the tree was just he likes to
sing he sings all the time oh you will
be in the car yeah well sing together I
I know the words the things though and
he really doesn't so